so then this is the realm of
mathematicians right because we're
thinking of all of this stuff which is
all mattes what kind of mathematical
knowledge could be used to solve this
problem because this is a big problem
and there's you know there's billions
trillions of dollars every year that
rides on solving this problem and it has
been solved okay so I'm going to show
you one of the most ingenious solutions
to it's not the only one it's not unique
but it'll it'll bend your brain a little
bit okay I know it bet my brain a little
bit when I learnt it this is symmetric
photography right what do you think it
would be cold if this photography was
not symmetrical in nature asymmetric
cryptography so new little subheading
asymmetric
okay he's the picture right here both
people have the same key basically okay
but this is thinking about well what if
what if right the encryption and the
decryption processes right well actually
like you know if you know how it was it
ripped it in this case you know how to
decrypt it you know how to decipher it
but what if there was a way to encrypt
messages and know how is encrypted but
they're not being able to decipher it
what if this was not symmetrical like so
so in order to help you understand let
me give you a picture which is a an
alternative to this okay
I've still got person eight here we go
person a in the middle okay why don't
let me change it up a little bit suppose
person hey doesn't just want to
communicate with one person right once
the communicate we'd say oh I don't know
twenty-nine people okay so what I want
what I want
has changes now this is me what I want
is to be able to communicate with all
twenty-nine a few okay and for you to be
able to send messages to me securely
okay now let's just think about how I
would do this under this model okay if I
want to send messages to everyone and
only I can I want I want to receive
messages from you guys and only I can
read them okay well one solution would
be I get twenty nine sets of one-time
pads okay
and I give all of you one and I keep all
twenty-nine I have to keep all
twenty-nine right and then every time I
get a message from okay here's one from
tourists I go and look through my pilot
like here's tarisha's one-time pad and
then I decide for using that okay
and then I get a message from Annabel
okay this is Annabel Swan and I look up
and so on that's awful not just for the
fact that I need 29 one-time pads right
it's confusing so here's my alternative
he's all of you guys out here on the
side okay I'm not gonna have the time to
draw 29 if you saw just for a fourth
okay instead of handing out one-time
pads okay my keys as it were what I do
is I hand to all of you guys everyone
the same
see I hand you all not keys but locks
okay so here are my little padlocks
okay now just think about this right
think about how clever this is right
because this mathematically this
ingenious but if I give you all the same
lock okay what happens is you compose
your message right you're putting in a
box and you slap the lock on okay now
you can't read the message but you don't
need to read the message it's not for
you you know it was in it anyway because
you wrote it right the only person who
can open the message now is the person
with the key namely me right so I've got
one key one key and it unlocks all of
your messages and as soon as you slap
the lock on no one else can read it
except for me okay no even if you've got
the lock right you can have the lock but
not be able to open it does that make
sense you can close the padlock in like
oh crap it's stuck right and I need the
person with the key to open this up for
me question
okay alright so let's come back to this
right so this idea that you are now in
possession of this lock okay what power
does that give you okay well yes I
suppose you could both lock up a message
in the same way but then what are you
going to do with that message once you
had it well but the whole point is that
for instance okay so let's let's push on
there so so here's Nikita right and on
you what to send a message to me okay
and so so here's your message right here
it is and you put a lock on it okay
now then this person down here who's who
looks pretty shifty yeah yeah let's make
it that's my good solution to rush
what's to know what's in this message
okay now let's just the scenario you
were talking about is if if he had the
exact same message right and locked it
up in the exact same way okay which is
to say all the locks are identical okay
if you guys then send those to me then
yes the messages would be identical okay
and there'd be a lot using the same lock
and I wouldn't I would decrypt them with
my key and they would sure enough come
up exactly the same if you said hello
and if you said hello well that's right
but that was on the assumption that he
actually knew your original message in
the first place right so if he comes to
a message secondhand and he didn't know
what you sent he would need my key to
open it up all right
so everyone having the walks is no
compromise on my security okay this is
the whole point that a lot doesn't give
you the same information as a key unlike
here right unless of course you're a
locksmith in any way okay so the point
is though I'm giving out locks it's a
it's a fundamentally different idea it's
not symmetrical okay
now this is the this is the sort of the
analogy right but how does this work
mathematically because you know have you
ever played that game have you ever had
someone say okay everyone think of a
number
thank you for number okay and then they
tell you something like okay multiply it
by 5 and subtract 1 then take the last
digit madam orlaf or something like that
right
and then magically at the end I say no
this is your number seven right and
you're like oh yeah here's the thing if
you if you write all that down
it's like symmetric encryption you can
work out exactly what's happened and you
can work out how I did the trick if you
write it down but here there's this idea
that I can give you some kind of
mathematical block that even when you
have the lock you still can't work it
out with all the all the time in the
world you'll be able to work it out so
the question is how does that work right
well I'm going to give you an example